on this episode we talk Vimeo the change
on Facebook profile pics and strategy
around speeches
yes
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 150 of
the ask gary vee show feel really good
today successful trip to London you know
I think we got to start recognizing the
fact that enormous amounts of money can
be made if you follow my Jets prediction
I am now for four as in fact Stefan one
should make a little graphic of all four
Instagram official predictions let that
takeover to screen right now and hold it
for a couple of seconds because I'm on
fire
I mean 1914 ends up 27 port have been
really in this not alive I've been in
the zone
so the Jets win the Dolphins have to
fire their coach I'm feeling really good
I'm where Buster screens Jersey he
dominated the game things are looking up
by week this upcoming week so I get to
relax and just sit back just sit back
and watch other teams lose so that's
exciting for me and the London show was
remarkable as a matter of fact that last
eight minutes has to become a video in
itself we need to talk about that that
caught everybody's attention if you
didn't watch episode 149 make sure you
do that
the schmarvard shirt is out about people
are enjoying that feeling good 150 a
milestone but in the way that we roll
here no special thrills nothing you know
will reserve those for the hundreds if
we can get the 200 that would be
exciting and so India it's good to see
you well good stuff thank you
India let's get into the Shah
I hope your sparkling waters delicious
really good thank you good let's do it
Joe Joe oh by the way before we get into
the show we released this morning a very
important film to me way too many people
think that entrepreneurship is a young
man's sport
and it is absolute golden era much like
the golden era of this show the golden
era for 40 to 80 year-old entrepreneurs
so step on put it up right here let it
play a little bit actually as a matter
of fact can you guys yeah of course you
can do is just let it play a little bit
while we do this first question have it
right here play a little bit while we do
the show let's link it up in YouTube and
Facebook and more importantly so many of
you have 40 to 80 year old entrepreneurs
and your friends and family network you
may not realize they're entrepreneurs
because they grew up in a time where
that wasn't practical I'd like you to
watch six minutes for the next 60 years
they're like I like how we went with it
alright India Joe Joe an obsessed world
how do you hammer home the truth that
Wine Library TV succeeded because of you
not the daily videos interesting so
Joe's saying that that the daily
consistency which seems like a proxy to
success isn't the reason it was
successful it was more of me and my
talents Joe I think the answer is
they're both correct I mean I would
totally disagree with you
that if I mean I lived it if I had quit
after the nine-month mark it was me I
did it a lot of things would be
different today like that just wouldn't
have been offend that a foundational
piece of my narrative I wouldn't have
broken out into web 2.0 culture which
would have then not allowed me to be a
top 25 follow person on Twitter during
that era would have not allowed me to
network in South by Southwest and meet
all the founders of the future most
important companies there surely be no
opportunity in 2008 to have dinner with
sucks at South by when it asked so you
know I think that yes and I've said it a
bunch of times no marketing and no
tactics will will help you if your
product is [ __ ] if I wasn't good enough
I could I could still be doing the
episodes there's plenty of people that
do I mean you can go watch on YouTube
right now
somebody's been putting
every day for the last seven years and
still has eight thousand subscribers and
isn't getting any traction because
there's not good enough and and being
good enough is the variable number one
but to downplay the consistency of the
work ethic and look I'm feeling it now
with the askgaryvee show the you know in
london seven selfies right seven people
literally walk in the streets Gary Gary
I'm feeling much more brand equity
because of the content that I'm putting
it out and honestly I'm feeling it a lot
more over the last sixty in ninety days
than I did over the first year of this
show like momentum is a real thing even
the Jets game we were up twenty seven to
seven or you know and then it started
getting a little hairy because for the
last eighteen 20 minutes Miami basically
had the momentum we held on momentum is
real in sports and in life and in
business and the only way you gain
momentum is by putting down the
foundation of work that gives you the
chance for momentum so momentum just
doesn't come out of thin air it's a play
it's a moment it's consistency it's
putting in the work and so joe i i i
don't pound that home because I think
both matt are quite a bit but yes you
know no marketing solves a bad product
Samantha Samantha how do you feel about
the box do you even know who something
at the Fox is Brett
d-roc Stefan listen good
Samantha asks how do you feel about a
short video in place of your profile
picture on facebook motion sick or sick
move you decide motion sickness or sick
that you know I think if culture is real
people like it you know I think
storytelling a storytelling I think they
both can work I think it comes down to
how good the gif is you know like I
think it comes just like how it comes
down to the picture so it's a it created
to me there's more upside in the fact
that it just creates a little bit more
creative freedom the rock is that what
you were emailing me about you want one
of those right yeah I mean I D rock once
it goes easily all about the video no
I'm glad I mean I think it's I
appreciate everybody asking and you know
this is not something I'm massively
passionate about meaning I think this
falls in the same category about a
company's name if your animated gif your
little video is good and clever I'll
capture people's attention I think for
the short term over the next three
months it's probably a smart tactic
because in a world of a feed you'll
stand out because it's new and so I
think if you want to go there for a
little bit more awareness you do it
right now as a matter fact I'm going to
now tell Dirac to pick some part of this
answer to be my motion video just for
kicks and giggles would be very meta and
and so yeah I think I think over the
next 36 months it's a smart tactic that
might give you a little bit more uptick
in awareness in a feed crowd noise feed
culture but I think it comes down to the
video or it comes down to the picture
one of the biggest reasons one thing I
will say is I didn't change my picture
on Twitter for a very long time even
though I no longer looked like that dude
which I think there's a pet peeve of
mine I just couldn't give up the
consistency of you know you're so visual
the amount of times I'm Twitter where
I'm like women that's Rick he must have
changed his profile like so I would say
that I like
the idea of keeping something consistent
in the small icon worlds after you pick
something for a long period of time if
you're trying to build a brand if you're
trying to get your content seen Irina
asks you seem to be everywhere
are you democratic about your talks or
do you have a strategy in place for
public speaking Irene I have a strategy
about everything so I was strategy for
my public speaking at this point in my
career try not to speak much unless I'm
getting paid my very expensive fee it's
a promise I made myself and my wife so
there's that but what I am NOT getting
paid it is absolutely a disproportionate
opportunity to do one of two things
which is build my brand and you know if
if I have to speak where I spoke
recently where Hillary Clinton note was
first and Steve Forbes was behind me and
I was in the middle that's a good brand
positioning 90% of crowd 98% of crowd
didn't know who I was but they sure knew
that I was one of those three people and
that means something and that makes them
Google me up a little bit more the other
thing that I do is I really want to
support certain communities New Jersey
tech scene the Harlem Tech scene is
something that's that I'm going to be
doing in the future
you know interns young people so there's
something that emotionally feels right
to me that I know that if I do it people
in the future will do it as well because
that organization can leverage my name
and I'm giving back to something that
means something to me
Jersey you know kind of like cut the
come-up underdog area you know
youngsters those are things that I'll
invest my time into there's no like sure
know that's all like no sure Matthew
asks what's the next industry to be
turned upside down because they aren't
adjusting to business models to fit
changes in technology I mean the answer
is everything and you need to break out
product
the reason the hotel industry and the
limousine service industry have been
thrown upside down is because
entrepreneurs came and attacked at full
throttle
you know the refrig appliances smart
appliances are coming so all appliances
are on call retail brands now can go
direct to consumer so I you know I think
we'll see that play out over the next 10
years TV media big media conglomerate
companies have to adjust to the
over-the-top networks and all the
infrastructure they have in place to to
be very expensive to produce television
like the products when people can just
do it like this or or over the top as a
new distribution game the Internet is
the middleman period and so anybody who
was in the middle is on call and that's
most things and so I think every
industry is is primed for disruption
that's why I'm so excited about this
generation it's why back to the film
it's why I do believe a 48 year old who
has a 9 to 6 job can do something about
it from 7:00 to 2:00 in the morning if
they want to be an entrepreneur because
there's so much opportunity so ripe so
many things are convoluted the way we
get wills there's a start-up I got
involved with that's incredible abortion
abortion is such an emotionally tough
thing to begin with if you're in that
position
oftentimes generalizing obviously it can
be an offensive move as well but when
you're going through something like that
and then you have to go through the
convoluted paperwork
where an app can solve everything in a
minute like literally anything that
takes time the DMV like anything that
takes time that is predicated on paper
or or legacy or keeping humans in jobs
like toll booth collectors like come on
it's 2016 like seriously let no
disrespect and you might be watching and
you are or have a friend or relative
that's a tollbooth collector like no
joke like they can make that money doing
something that can probably bring them
more upside than sitting on their phone
playing angry dirt that means it's like
it's insanity there's a lot of insanity
out there and I'm excited about insanity
getting punched in the mouth by
innovation innovation insanity
I'm very focused this morning for 150
have you noticed the silliness is out
the door we're getting real here because
innovations punching insanity in the
mouth super super serious I'm gonna get
even more serious on this question Wow
last one so that's right from Malik
Malik Malik asks will Vimeo ever be able
to successfully compete with YouTube
without running ads or will they keep
thriving is a smaller competitor week
the Vimeo is a wonderful place it's a
tremendously interesting niche place for
video but it doesn't compete with
YouTube and and um I don't see it really
competing with YouTube meaning there's
just two very different things that's
like saying I'm Ken Hamilton the
Broadway play compete with Star Wars it
depends on what you're competing on can
it compete from a quality standpoint and
experience everyone absolutely it's
probably winning a la Vimeo can it
compete on a scale and impact standpoint
and dollar amounts and money making
absolutely not
Vimeo is not built to compete with
YouTube's smartly when David plays
Goliath's game it goes out of business
when David plays David's game it wins
and I think Vimeo has done a very nice
job carving out its proper niche within
a video landscape and recognizing it
doesn't have the dollars infrastructure
scale momentum and oomph to compete on
YouTube's game against YouTube
so maturing as we get into the 150s
maybe this will be the decade of
seriousness yeah you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them